a pizza topped with other smaller pizzas
and Chewbacca gone bad
it's Episode six of IMG as fall
approaches BuzzFeed brings us pugs
wearing jackets 103 pictures of pugs
wearing jackets but don't worry by the
time this cat catches the balloons you
will have seen them all
tada
and in the spirit of Halloween check out
these hair o lanterns buns you showed us
art on nails these kind of nails
delicious refreshing pokey sorry
pokemons Rousey and Trekkie
but now let's just talk about thumbnails
the YouTube kind you may have been
impressed that I managed to fit two
girls on this video thumbnail well not
quite it's just one girl Abby and
Brittany Hensel share two hearts but
just one body I'd heard about them
before but it wasn't until yesterday
that I found this treasure trove of
pictures of them if you want to see a
video about the girls check the link in
the description below which is where
you'll find links to all the images in
this show in the video the girls say
they're interested in dating and
yesterday I found some great dating
advice first shower with some beer soap
and beer shampoo dress formerly light a
romantic beer scented candle or feet by
the light of a chandelier finish off
with some beer cupcakes trade mp3s and
if you died of alcohol poisoning get
buried in one of these and Jeff break
jump jump jump jump yeah yeah oh um good
night damage comm assembled a treasury
of animals with their heads or more
stuck in things this one actually
happened to me in college when I heard
8-bit wood I thought I'd fit right in
but no it's really just that wood
sculptures of 8-bit wonders but now it's
time machine time via blaster Keanu
Reeves bruce willis samuel l.jackson
george lucas and jean-claude van damme
damn these women used to be these men so
here's a challenge from the annual
optical illusion contest can you tell
which one of these is a man and which is
a woman trick question they're the exact
same face but this one has higher than
normal contrast and this one lower than
normal it's not actually clear yet why
just make such a difference ambigrams
are designs that can be read as one word
or more from different viewpoints rotate
this word and look it still says
ambigram play hard light is a particle i
mean wave oh look my name and come in go
away for this one sit a comfortable
distance from the shape then move your
face right up next to it it will appear
to become brighter and then darker as
you move back away just like contrast
and gender the reason for this illusion
is not quite known yet but look at this
a bra that can be turned into a gas mask
and while these cats morph into
croissants I'm going to shout out
facebook.com / Vsauce gaming it's where
you guys can view and submit your own
favorite images from the week for
instance user Jojo taught me everything
I needed to know ever in life and now
it's time for a new section my favorite
YouTube thumbnails
this week it's rhett and Link Charlie
James 1975 and Jerry blue who's here
with me right now to discuss his
favorite images Jerry hello thanks Steve
and Michaels it's Michael Stevens first
up is the hottest pic on global maps
it's french fry land
I think that's France next up is a mind
teaser if
flip the Applebee's logo upside down it
spells balls last is a picture from
National Geographic it's Janice Bieber
playing call of duty against Bruce Lee
riding a unicorn okay not not a single
thing you just said is true
not even the burbs okay
Jerry doesn't know what IMG is but he
also doesn't know how to review video
games and does that anyway click here to
see what I mean it's worth it
IMG we'll be back next week thanks for
watching